o campeão do mundo
[Música]
vamos continuar no peru em meados de
fevereiro
[Música]
a menina e ele for bem se é real menin a
[ __ ]
a partir daí a hora que aceite meu
canalha
ao todo com vocês é o que bilhões é
muito obrigado por essa marca parabéns a
vocês na verdade os 20 milhões são vocês
não só por nenhum só tô falando besteira
que na fé da câmera muito obrigado mesmo
parabéns pra você e os 20 milhões se
você faz parte dos 20 milhões não
esquece
já aquele que gostei agora no começo do
vídeo pode ficar por aí vai
eu estou muito feliz com a marca do
governo dilma eu tô triste com o que vem
acontecendo com o brasil porque
antigamente era melhor coisa melhor
antigamente hoje cara as coisas mudaram
irmão e no noturno mudou tudo sei lá
cantuta nem que me falar eu só vi na
tomada que não segura bateria para nada
antigamente o celular grava pra [ __ ]
hoje se o mergulhador está no fundo do
mar e achar o nokia ainda para cumprir
sem bateria com um site chamado da
namorada na agulha do domingo até às
tomadas as tomadas todas tema tst com
essa merda em lugar nenhum porque as
casas são tudo antigas não tem essa
turma aí você pergunta possui lacado no
hotel em alguma tomada dessas de três
assim a responsável não dessa turma não
tem como dizer então a gente vai poder
gastar mais de 3 a 5 311 s6 problema não
é igual à do computador grande não é a
56 o cara só tem eu ficar a meu deus
graças a deus e onde é que é de trás da
cama rua rahmeh não me diga pra que é
uma tomada atrás da cama pra quem voltou
a atacar me disse foi tão bacana em
outro lugar no bote tomatada campo
porque aí meu amigo sei lá as telas
dessas bosques e lá são feitas para
quebrar esse quebra a tela do celular e
leva pra você ataca falo isso aqui só
porque é só porque eu sei lá é sua tela
só tem tela é o cara falando que não
tinha película a então tá entende por
que buscam tinha película a pele que
antigamente era noite que não deixava o
celular cair não tinha mãos a etapa
segurar a tijolo que segurar com força e
nunca ia só não cair e hoje em dia o
capô do iphone a mãe me internar alguém
mexendo em cima ela cai na cara ai
machucou e deixou ela cair tocar antiga
me deixasse motorola gps para sua cabeça
ou fraturado o crânio a mãe chegar
porque em cima da cama disse o negócio
em cima da tampa é isso isso já estava
se masturbando em cima não é o pedaço do
meu em ferro que só estão pegando época
pai essa época que estão vivendo é
paticamente época você podia trocar
carcaça do celular
isso sim era top menino voltava a
carcaça do batman a menina metida a
carga da hello kitty era lindo me a
vocês
com sua namorada botar por 2 a 1 em cima
da mesa parece que o céu lá tá namorando
um com o outro baque na história do rock
teatral hoje em dia pra consertar o
celular tem que ser autorizado é ateu
que autorizar rapidamente isso não é
qualquer ser humano consertava um
celular porque era fácil é também estava
desligando leva lá pra ver o que é moça
que é isso aqui afundou a tecla afundou
até grave com a faca de mesa faca de
cozinha ele tirava terra tudo certo o
quanto é que israel hoje em dia sei lá
só tem uma tecla uma tecla só que a
tecla da impressão digital que só essa
agora quebrou essa tecla nos voltar pra
consertar que até que o rapaz ainda na
base dos 1700 patacas do carai seu melro
a tecla há pois que tem que botar essa
película que é para proteger essas
coisas não quebra tudo tecnologia
negócio de praia gente é um flash o
flash será a desgraça e quanto quer
flash não tá com flash enquanto não quer
o flecha parece um leão escuro branco dá
por tudo escuro que na foto não flash
tal tomar aí junta todo mundo tirar vai
o para ele não sair o flash não agora
quando não pode aparecer o flash parece
que o sata mais em bem devagarzinho
livro flash e mônica lima mulher de zezé
de camargo e luciano e do chute não
faltou matar a mãe tira uma fica
doidinho erro tirar bem devagarzinho tem
que ser bem devagarzinho pelo ver que
ele viu passar mal com aquino tecnologia
é a gente observa a mãe não quer aceitar
um celular que preste para sua mãe ela
parece que quer afastar a tecnologia da
intel que não liga pra ela quer passar
pra você ver rosa o mec quer falar com
ele tem de ficar rock funk
vou passar pra ele toma não um fim
a oit a rosa tudo bom
o minc tem tudo o que quer pois não se
frustrar um livro podia companhia
ficarem tanto leis playstation
playstation a você ganha um jogo da vida
criança fica triste em depressão mas
depois de um tempo ela começa a
trabalhar e comprar seu próprio esteio
hoje não tem mais isso não fala com a
mãe
eu queria que eles ficaram com pressa em
inglês tem som pra mim mas eu não
preciso de arte 138 stations oito
tanques já sei nem no japão e você já
tem até esse daí aviso nintendo 64
nem meus amigos demais juízes têm um
briefing mãe tucano e tente 18 ao pai da
prefeita eo efeito na mão caso que
assistir desenho ela bota no canal do
desenho
olha que loucura hoje existe o canal do
desenho uma criança assistida z na hora
que quiser ter que assistir alice botta
no canal do brasil no youtube tem o
canal do youtube faz 10 em catiguá mente
não existia o canal do desenho existir o
horário do desenho da emissora tinha o
horário do desenho aquele horário pra
gente era criança era grave e 11 horas
começaram o dragon ball então a gente
fazia tudo em casa para 11 horas não
penada a mãe mandava você fazer só será
exigida bom ea mãe só de pirraça e
começa a chorar de dragon ball kai
descem de luta carnificina morro sopo
etapa contava braço e oscar a e pescoço
é o gil me tem um canal do desenho que
ele pode botar qualquer paciente
qualquer desenho menino bota pra
assistir do returno é meu irmão ficou
muito doido karman que não é esse cara
que a gente vive e meu irmão que é isso
que quem está vivendo aqui eu sei o que
eu faço no âmbito é como fazer casa só
me resta dizer que tinha 4 de junho tem
show aqui em são paulo os espaços das
américas no dia 11 tem show em campo
grande lago congresso não sai muito
obrigado a assistir se viu até aqui você
gostou e já sabe aquele cnec não esquece
do lago fica muito feliz eu quero você
comente aqui no vídeo o que você mais
sente falta de antigamente que hoje não
tem volta lá no facebook você estão
esquecendo disso nessa publicação aqui ó
tá vendo vídeo novo antigamente era mais
legal foi que você fica lá em kurt e
marca seus amigos nos comentários que
também acho que taticamente é legal ele
esse vídeo vê se concorde se inscreve no
canal envenena o vídeo e as redes
sociais essa daqui vai aparecer como num
passe de mágica
bill segue lá é nóis valeu e bambam e
quero